so welcome back to the third and final
unum lecture given by Nina fedorov what
I want to do to start this third lecture
off is to relate the first two of Nina's
lectures to the work that you normally
associate with the Santa Fe Institute
and that in particular the study of
complex adaptive systems so let me
define the terms so I think we all have
an intuitive notion of what adaptation
is and so that's a directed change in a
system in response to changing
environmental stimuli where this change
typically improves some objective
function a critical components of
adaptation are learning and memory such
that individuals can improve their
future performance based on their past
history that's adaptation we also have
an intuitive notion of complexity and we
define it typically by exclusion you can
think of a system on the one hand of
being completely disordered and chaotic
now the other hand highly ordered an
almost crystalline and somehow in the
middle between those two poles of the
spectrum is where we observe complexity
so at the Santa Fe Institute we spend a
lot of time trying to invent
quantitative methods using mathematics
or using computer models to measure
complexity in natural systems and also
develop simple dynamical models that
manifest complexity based on the
operation of very simple rules such as
the rules of development described by
Nina but of course we don't restrict
ourselves only to development but also
to economics and ecosystems and so forth
now one of the things that you become
aware of when you work in these complex
adaptive systems is there's always a
risk of gravitating towards one of the
two poles of that spectrum on the one
hand if a system becomes changes too
slowly becomes frozen it becomes
excessively regular and is unable to
manifest interesting behavior on the
other hand if the system changes too
quickly the entropy increases and it
falls into a kind of chaotic disorder
the first of Nina's talks was really
about adaptation in the various
responses to the environment
in the second talk was about models and
mechanisms of genetic change that
facilitate adaptation but not don't push
change too fast that the system is
incapable repairing itself and in fact a
number of questions from the audience
yesterday related to that how is it that
the system itself can deal with such an
elevated rate of change
I think the surprising thing about
modern genetics is that biological
systems sit much closer to the
disordered side of that end of that
spectrum than we thought was possible so
that brings us to tonight's lecture on
genetically modified plants and I
suspect actually thinking about this and
it's just a conjecture that a lot of our
unconscious fears relating to genetic
modification have to do with a notion
that we have that perhaps by
accelerating the rate of natural plant
evolution well cause the system to fall
into that gravitational end of the
spectrum associated with maximum
disorder and become irreparable chaotic
now whereas the first two lectures were
completely free of anthropic influences
the third one puts human beings squarely
at the center and as I said a species
that often is rather mitotic myopic and
capable of rapidly accelerating natural
rates of evolutionary change the
question is how far are we free to
modify nature the only way to know this
is through careful scientific experiment
free from the fetters of political and
economic scrutiny the interference and
with a knife early on the highest
ethical standards
these essentially the topics of today's
lectures now given the topic of the
lecture I'm sure that we're going to be
quite divided as a community and Nina
represents one very well-informed
position many of us I should say at the
Institute don't necessarily share Nina's
position in fact many of us have had
some very heated debates where Nina
typically comes out on top I have to say
since she said
much better informed than we are but I
would just say to might have seen some
of the security here I just like to say
that if you do have a particularly
strong opinion on the matter wait until
the discussion at the end of the lecture
because as you see we have the table set
up we're going to give ourselves more
time tonight to have a more lengthy
discussion and be considerate of other
people's opinions and other people's
rights to ask questions finally I'd like
to thank ginger Richardson for putting
together the entire alum series I don't
know where where are you ginger over
there so thanks again I think we should
give her a round up for
it's okay with no more delays you know
what an introduction that's a hard act
to follow I hope it's not a huge
disappointment so to all of you who came
before welcome back to all of you who
are here the first time welcome tonight
we take on a very contemporary and a
very contentious issue are GMOs the
answer to the world's ongoing problems
our numbers are expected to climb from
slightly over six billion to a
staggering nine billion people in coming
decades
well GM foods create the EE Green
Revolution that the Rockefeller
Foundation's Gordon Conway says will be
needed to feed the world's people where
are GMOs really a public menace as many
groups like Greenpeace would like you to
think are they so new and so different
and so unnatural that we have to fear
the consequences of bringing them into
our food supply is there evidence that
they are harmful to us to the
environment okay about me
I'm going to be perfectly upfront so you
know where I'm coming from I'm a
scientist I'm a plant scientist a
geneticist and a molecular biologist
have had the extraordinary fortune to be
a participant in developing the field of
plant molecular genetics
I've watched with excitement and wonder
as our ability to improve plants using
molecular techniques has developed over
recent decades I've participated in the
government's oversight of the
locations of this technology I served on
the NIH read DNA becoming a DNA Advisory
Committee in the 1980s as well as with
groups convened by the Environmental
Protection Agency of EPA the US
Department of Agriculture USDA and the
Food and Drug Administration the FDA and
the National Academy of Sciences I've
watched the growing worldwide
controversy about GMOs with growing
dismay several years ago I decided if I
were going to be the Lorax and speak for
the trees I'd better know what I was
talking about I've learned a lot about
the history of genetic modification of
crops I learned as much as I could about
the concerns that people were raising
and then with the able assistance of a
marvelous science writer Nancy Brown I
wrote Mendel in the kitchen I can't tell
you that everything in there is
absolutely correct
but we sure tried our best to check and
recheck our facts I have just an hour
with you and I'll try to share the most
important things I've learned but the
most important thing that I want to say
to you about this I can say right now I
would beg you to keep an open mind keep
asking questions and keep seeking
reliable information enough said let's
start at the beginning what is a GMO
what GMO means is genetically modified
organism know today that is almost
exclusively used to designate an
organism that was modified by molecular
techniques no is genetic modification
new the answer is no it's not people
have been modifying plants to be better
sources of food for themselves for
somewhere between 50 and 15,000
maybe even as much as 50,000 years how
do we know that well let me give you
some simple common-sense examples wild
plants have mechanisms to disperse their
seeds think about the lovely parachute
that a dandelion seed has to take it to
a new place
think about birds those are simply seeds
with hooks to hang on to animals to
disperse them to be collected by people
for food the seeds have to stay on the
plant so a very early kind of mutation
that people selected was one that
prevents the plant from scattering its
seeds now let me show you what that
means I can get this to move there we go
this is a wild grass called teosinte it
turns out to be what people turned into
our modern corn plant with its huge ear
to which the kernel sticks so tightly
that can be they can be collected in a
hole nourishing package by a machine the
harvester these two looks so different
than when people first discovered the
essenti they thought it was a different
species but it turns out that they are
so closely related that they interbreed
and they produce offspring that are
everything in between from what the
teosinte plant produces to the ear of
corn so this over here is the seed
structure of the teosinte plant and it
has two characteristics that are
absolutely utterly useless for people it
has what is technically called a dis
articulating reqest
that is the seeds scatter when the when
that structure dries down and second the
seeds are hard as rock indeed they have
rock in them they have silica deposits
the reason for that is very simple these
creatures the plants have used animals
use animals to disperse their seeds and
it doesn't do any good
for the plant it doesn't it isn't able
to disperse its seed if it's digested by
the animal so the point is that the that
they've seed has to survive through the
digestive tract and so the first thing
that people select for is the ability to
stick to the to the to the plant
now these structures that that the
teosinte plant makes are actually
produced technical challenge there is at
the top of the plant this is really a
grass plant this thing is a chute that
normally grows out it's actually
telescoped and if you think about an ear
of corn with all the leaves on top of it
all of this is a telescope chute of the
original teosinte plant
and so that's number one and number two
the way that archaeologists can tell is
that the mutations that cause the seeds
to stick that create in technical jargon
the non disarticulated rackets are
detectable even in archaeological
samples and even the earliest little
tiny ears of corn that have been picked
up from that date back 6,000 years
already had pretty much this structure
so people selected for this very early
on and the other thing that's incredibly
striking is that even though they didn't
have trains and planes and trucks and
all the mechanisms that we have for
dispersing things once people developed
this plant it's spread in ancient terms
extremely rapidly so the genetic
constitution of some of the strains that
are in north america originated in
mexico and they were they were already
the same exact mutations are detectable
in archaeological specimens from 3,000
years ago up in new mexico up in this
area so
going on let's look at some other
examples of genetic modifications here's
some familiar foods that people think of
quite naturally this is a very bizarre
mutation actually what this is a head of
cauliflower of course but what is this
stuff this stuff is a mutation that
causes the plant to make flower buds and
flower buds and flower buds and Flora's
it's just a stuttering mutant that can't
get out of the loop of making flower
buds and then there's giant garlic that
was a gift of Luther Burbank Luther
Burbank actually was a remarkable person
he was one of the first plant breeders
that understood the plasticity of plants
and how much you can do by simply
selecting nature's constant from amongst
nature's constant variety and then their
Tomatoes actually this is from a very
poisonous family the nightshade family
and the wild relatives of tomatoes are
rarely even read and they certainly
aren't these huge balloons that we think
are Tomatoes today
and then there's seedless oranges who
did this thought about a seedless orange
seeds are the things that plants use to
reproduce we like our seedless oranges
all of the seedless oranges are
propagated by people by cloning and then
of course they're seedless so
grapefruits as well but I want to tell
you about how this particular strain the
real red grapefruit was developed lest
you think much genetic modification is
new so back in the last century people
read
developed ways of accelerating the rate
of genetic change that is in here
in natural populations by virtue of
cosmic rays and transposons that is part
of the changes inherent in the organism
as all of you that came last night
realize and part of it is simply from
cosmic radiation people learn how to use
chemical mutagens and radiation and how
this was created was by actually cutting
a bunch of shoots of already slightly
red pinkish grapefruit sending them off
to Brookhaven National Laboratory where
they were irradiated and then shipped
back to Texas and then grown for a
number of years and looked at constantly
the readers were looking for mutations
and they finally identified this as a
mutant mutant branch propagated it and
released it some years later now what I
need to tell you is that that's not a
very tidy process irradiation makes all
kinds of mutations and probably half or
more of the varieties that are used
today as plant foods have some
irradiation mutagenesis in their
background why does this work why didn't
we regulate it largely because and this
is a little bit of an answer to David's
challenge largely because people most of
the mutations that happen are what's the
technical term is deleterious they're
harmful to the organism but breeders
learned that they could simply kill the
plants that didn't look right so it's
constant loss process of selecting the
things that have the qualities and the
growth properties that the breeders
wanted as I said earlier the term GMO is
used just for molecular modifications
today these are also called recombinant
DNA techniques and genetic engineering
which seems like a very off-putting term
we don't have a problem with engineering
cars or bridges or computers but food
hmm isn't that fooling with Mother
Nature well as you just saw over a few
tens of thousands of years we've done a
pretty good job of cajoling mutants from
Mother Nature to provide a vast array of
plants that produce appealing and
nourishing people foods during the 20th
century we learned how to accelerate
that process with chemicals in radiation
to hurry along mother nature's slow pace
of making mutations with cosmic rays and
transposons as such so what about the
new molecular techniques well here too
we've learned some of Mother Nature's
tricks and put them to work there's a
thumbnail sketch of recombinant DNA
technology bacteria have in addition to
their big chromosomes these little mini
chromosomes called plasmids bacteria
also make a large array of DNA cutting
enzymes called restriction enzymes the
ecor1 you see in this diagram is such a
restriction enzyme and it cuts DNA in
the way that it leaves overhanging ant
sticky ends imagine two pieces of velcro
and you leave the hands hanging over you
can stick them together and that's
basically what's happening here so the
purple piece of DNA is from a different
source perhaps a corn plant or a fruit
fly it is the plasmid is cut open and
the DNA is cut up with the same
restriction enzyme and stuck together
and there's one more piece there's a an
enzyme which is appropriately called a
ligase that legates this thing together
and then those plasmids are introduced
into bacteria the bacteria are first
treated with a little calcium chloride
which makes them take up the DNA the
reasons nobody really understands and
then those bacteria with the plasmids in
them are spread out now you see three
plasmids here but in fact it's done in
such a way that most cells have just one
plasmid and then those cells are spread
out on a petri dish like this
that selects those particular plasmids
that received the bacteria that received
the plasmids and it looks like this in
reality and each one of those single
cells containing a single plasmid with a
unique sequence grows into many millions
of cells that constitute the little
colony each one is a different cloned
piece of DNA basically it's like making
many many copies of some kind of a
document and that gives biochemists or
mafia Bhalla just as they're called now
large numbers of copies of it and it
turned it also produces the protein it
codes for but this basically allows the
biochemist
to analyze the the both the structure of
the DNA and to modify it now
today for example people are treated
with human insulin that's produced in
just this way a human insulin gene was
inserted into a plasmid which then makes
very large numbers of copies of it and
in turn produces the protein it codes
for this has been a tremendous medical
advance before recombinant insulin
people were usually treated with Pig
insulin with diabetes our growing
problem worldwide it would have been
very difficult to keep up with the
demand and because it's a foreign
protein
people often reacted badly to Pig
insulin that's something we accept today
but I will tell you that back in the 70s
there was a good deal of Fleur about it
even that role established technology
now to understand contemporary molecular
approaches to modifying crop plants you
need to meet one more actor nature's own
genetic engineer a soil bacterium called
agrobacterium tumefaciens this bacterium
causes the formation of galls which are
tumors on the stems and roots of many
plants the understanding of how the
bacterium forms the galls the pioneering
made the work that made it possible to
use agro bacterium to carry new genes
into plants was done by the late Jeff
Schell
a dear friend and a fantastic scientist
in fact I think this picture came from
him back when we were collaborating the
animation that I will show you next
gives you an idea of what was understood
through basic research about the Gaul
formation in a route this clever
creature carries around plant genes that
it doesn't use but when it detects an
opening meaning a wounded plant cell it
swims over to it and slips those genes
into the plant these genes reprogrammed
the plant a bit first to grow this tumor
and second to make a special compound
that the bacteria in the vicinity can
use for nourishment very clever the
tumor doesn't kill the plant it just
coaxes it to make food for the bacteria
so this is a little animation the source
of the innovation by the way is
immediately under it that represents the
chemical signals sent out by the wound
and then the bacterium detects those and
swims up the concentration gradient it
has these lovely little flagella that
let it swim along and then when it gets
to the the actual cell it attaches and
it's carrying a plasmid it's a bit of
its own and then it transfers a piece of
that plasmid into the cell here it comes
again and then a most remarkable thing
happens there's a mechanism that
actually cuts the DNA and allows the DNA
to integrate and that as I said
reprograms the cell to make this little
tumor which then produces compounds
called opines no Polly
octopus there's a bunch of different
ones but they can serve as a sole food
source for the bacterium in the vicinity
so here's the little girl it doesn't
kill the plant just feeds the bacterium
kind of an interesting process so what
she'll and others did was basically to
remove the cancer forming genes that the
gall forming gene
the Gaul is the name for the tumour and
then they developed ways of
incorporating a junu gene putting
agrobacterium to work as a gene delivery
system in order to improve croplands
here's what it looks like in the
laboratory so you take a leaf this is
actually a tobacco leaf not because it's
tobacco but it turns out that tobacco is
particularly easy to transform and so
many laboratories use it as a test
system so you cut it believes and you
dip them in a bacterial culture that
cutting them up causes them to release
the chemicals that stimulate the
bacterium to transfer its DNA the leaf
pieces are simply dipped in a bacterial
suspension then a couple of days later
they're transferred to a medium that
contains an antibiotic to eliminate the
bacteria in a compound that permits only
the cells that receive the DNA to grow
the medium also contains plant hormones
that stimulate the cells to grow in
these little lumps these are called
Kelly you could see these little white
lumps and the miracle of plants is that
if you take those hormones away that
lumpy thing begins to make leaves and
then it begins to look like a plant and
then it makes roots it develops into a
perfectly normal-looking plant but now
it has the gene that you added quite
remarkable okay that's the basic biology
out of it now let's look at some of the
things that have been done with these
molecular techniques to protect crop
plants from diseases and insects
this plant is infected with papaya
ringspot virus you could easily see how
the virus got its name by the spots but
paya doesn't look bad but here's what it
does to plants this is a healthy plant
and this is a virus infected plants
here's the critter that carries that are
here's the virus itself it's basically a
piece of nucleic acid in this case RNA
for those of you who came last night in
a protein coat and here's the little
insect that carries it around
when it sucks fluids from the leaf this
is actually leaf that it's sitting on
and it sucks up virus particles and
spreads it to the next plant that it
lands on now the virus abbreviated P RSV
was first discovered in Hawaii back in
the 1940s by the 1950s it had basically
wiped out the oahu's papaya industry
which then moved to the Big Island and
was kept relatively free of the virus
for several decades by constant
vigilance and rapid elimination of
affected trees this is a very difficult
virus to control because you simply
can't kill every insect that's flying
through an orchard it's extremely
difficult and people had spent years and
many millions of dollars trying to to
develop resistant varieties with very
little success
now the unlikely hero of this story is a
plant pathologist by the name of Dennis
Gonsalves he had worked for many many
years who's very familiar with the
disease he'd worked on it for many years
as I said with very little success but
back in the late 70s he heard that a
colleague in st. Louis Roger beachy had
used the kinds of techniques I just
described to you to introduce a viral
gene and some tomatoes and found that it
protected them from infection now I'll
show you how this actually works but the
original idea was that maybe like
animals you could inoculate a plant
against a disease and that wasn't such a
far-fetched idea actually because it
rested on observations going very far
back by plant pathologists that once a
field or a plant had been infected with
one virus it was now cross protected
against super infection with another
virus
that's called cross protection so now he
decided this is gonna solve this tried
to try out this new molecular approach
now papaya unfortunately isn't as easy
to transform with agrobacterium as many
other plants are but he persuaded a
colleague of his at Cornell John Sanford
to try using his newly invented gadget
that he called a gene gun to introduce
viral genes into papaya plants this
so-called gene gun actually shoots tiny
tiny particles of gold coated with DNA
through the plant cell wall plant cells
are enclosed enclosed in a box in fact
and that makes them very difficult to
introduce DNA to but it worked and when
the little particles deposit their their
cargo some of it goes into the nucleus
and gets incorporated into DNA no it's
not such an easy technique to do and it
took them more than a decade but by 1991
the first virus resistant plants were
ready and by 1992 they'd received
permission to carry out the first field
trials in Hawaii in collaboration with a
group at the University of Hawaii now
just about this time the virus was
beginning to get really out of control
in in Hawaii on the Big Island but by
1994 the USDA had approved the first
large-scale field tests and in fact the
USDA gave them wisely gave them
permission to actually grow seeds
because they knew that it would take
quite a long time to get through the
whole regulatory apparatus which
included safety testing required by the
USDA the EPA
the FDA and that actually took three
years and by that time the virus was bad
enough that it there were farmers were
going out of business
finally the approvals were obtained all
the safety testing was met and the seeds
were finally released in 1998 free of
charge to growers this was an academic
project there aren't many of them
because there aren't many groups that
can afford to keep going through all of
this but by night by by about two
thousand the Hawaiian industry had
started to bounce back and the
production had levels had gone back up
to pre 1995 levels now here the healthy
trees that carry the violin gene to me
this is a remarkable story it's as
remarkable as the history of
vaccinations and medicine and indeed
carrying the viral gene in essence
vaccinates the papaya plant against the
virus only by a very different mechanism
which has only been as understood in the
last few years when they actually did
this work they knew it worked but they
didn't know why let me show you how it
works a virus as I said earlier is
simply a packet of genes in this case
born on an RNA molecule in a protein
coat I've represented the protein coat
in these green ovals and the first thing
that happens when the virus is delivered
into the cell is that it gets undressed
and that allows the nucleic acid the RNA
to be replicated and that RNA then codes
for proteins those are more coat
proteins and that allows the virus to
reassemble and it's pretty much ready to
be picked up by the next insect that
comes along but meanwhile is pretty much
trashed the place and eventually such
infection will kill the plant as I
showed you
now what happens in these plants that
have a viral chain is quite remarkably
different so the minute that the protein
coat is removed there's a mechanism that
triggers the destruction of the RNA so
it never gets off the ground well is
this something that terrible that never
happens in nature no that's exactly how
plants become immune to viral infection
in fact very similar at least at a
formal level to how you become immune to
disease once you've had it the next time
the same virus is seen by your immune
system it recognizes it and destroys it
and so it is with plants once they've
been infected with a virus this
mechanism allows them to resist
reinfection what Gonzalez and his
colleagues did then was figure out how
to make the papaya tree immune to the
ringspot virus by expressing just a
little piece of the viral genetic
information enough to trigger the
mechanism but not enough to make the
plant sick thinks it's been infected
even though it hasn't been he's
considered a hero by the local farmers
and used to receive national and
international awards for this work but
he's also been attacked and vilified for
it by people and groups that are against
it on to corn and insect resistance
here's a healthy ear of corn and here's
a very common corn pest the European
corn borer and what it does to the corn
its most devastating effect is to hollow
out the stock so that the plant falls
over and dies sever biotechnology
companies the most affirmative which to
you probably would be Monsanto
transferred a gene from a soil bacterium
called bacillus thuringiensis
abbreviated BT which is why it's called
BT corn to plants
the bacterium itself has been used for
insect control for many decades because
it produces crystals of a protein that
is toxic to certain kind of insects but
perfectly innocuous to people it's just
another bit of protein to people it's
been sprayed from helicopters to control
gypsy moths organic farmers use it
extensively you can get at the hardware
store under a number of brand labels
including Dipel in fact it's considered
so safe that the EPA hasn't set what it
called tolerances for it the EPA's
tolerance is the maximum level of
chemicals such as a pesticide or
fungicide that is considered safe for
human health as a residue in food BT
corn is resistant at corn borer because
the plant itself expresses that protein
this means that farmers don't have to
use chemical pesticides to control this
pest which is extremely difficult to
control because of its boring lifestyle
the rapid adoption of BT corn and cotton
by farmers in many countries has
actually dramatically reduced pesticide
use but there turns out to be an
unexpected additional benefit of BT corn
which people really didn't anticipate
invading corn borers provide a path of
infection for fungi the most serious of
which are Fusarium ear rot and kernel
rot these fungi which make the white
stuff you can see on the upper ear also
produce some extremely toxic compounds
called human essence and aflatoxin which
cause serious neurological diseases and
death in animals and people their use of
BT corn dramatically reduces the
incidence of such contamination by such
fungal toxins a gift unexpected
let's talk a bit about golden rice rice
that is yellow because it makes more
vitamin A here's of this Taylor or Ingo
Potrykus a Swiss plant biologist that
you saw in an early slide and a
biochemist Peter buyer who collaborated
to develop vitamin a rich rice Ingo took
up the project more than 15 years ago
because he himself had experienced
hunger as a child having lost his father
in the Second World War and he wanted to
address a real problem that affect real
people who were much less fortunate than
he had a conference called together by
the Rockefeller Foundation which funds a
great deal of agricultural research the
attendees agreed that adding the ability
to produce vitamin A to rice a major
part of the diet of many people in
poorer countries would have huge health
benefits many children died of vitamin A
deficiency and adults have too little of
it can go blind now in guro was
determined that whatever he produced
would be freely available to farmers
everywhere being somewhat naive academic
scientists he was rather chagrin to
discover that he dilated some 70 patents
held by companies and that rice couldn't
be made available immediately but
eventually that problem was also solved
and most of the companies actually
donated their patent licenses to this
project today that project is overseen
by a group called the Golden Rice
humanitarian Board which is chaired by
the now retired professor Patricius Ingo
also admits to being shocked at the
extent to which he was vilified by
troops and individuals who are against
using molecular techniques now currently
the rice is being improved in field
tested it too must pass through a long
regulatory process before it is released
in addition to the field tests for how
well it stands up under various
condition conditions it's also being
tested
the bioavailability of vitamin a
precursor and simply for palatability
how good it tastes interestingly a
recent breakthrough at Syngenta will
allow much higher level of beta carotene
expression than was previously possible
one of the things that that Ingo was was
quite viciously attacked about was that
she people would have to eat you know 40
pounds of rice a day in order to get
enough vitamin A and that this was a
sham but in fact those problems are
being solved and eventually these
particular genes will be then they have
to be transferred to rice varieties that
are particularly well adapted to various
parts of the world I suspect that this
will eventually be released the question
would be will people accept him we don't
always make decisions about foods based
on what's best for us and people really
value the whiteness of rice so that's
the next challenge let's go on out to
consider some of the concerns people
express is it safe to eat DNA now this
is a very sophisticated audience but I
have to tell you that in surveys a
surprising number of people think that
the only foods that contain DNA are
those that have been genetically
modified by these techniques
well it turns out that all food contains
DNA the amount of extra DNA introduced
by molecular methods is about one part
in a million or a point zero zero zero
one percent DNA digestion begins in the
mouth and is completed in the stomach
and the digestive tract although small
bits can survive this doesn't change our
genes you've been eating a lot of
foreign DNA all of your life both plant
and animal DNA
the next question is this could GM foods
contain new toxins well all foods
contain chemicals that are toxic or
carcinogenic or both but generally only
a few concerned large quantities now
crop plants are plants you all know that
there are poisonous plants and crop
plants or plants which people have over
millennia either bred for decrease
toxicity or in some case figured out how
to reduce the type of toxicity by
cooking or some other treatment
nonetheless plant breeding both
traditional and contemporary can change
the abundance of a toxic compound
basically animals protect themselves
from insects and bacteria through their
chemical Arsenal's now this has happened
by traditional breeding there are two
very well-known cases when new where new
conventionally bred insect resistant
varieties of potato and celery turned
out to have elevated concentrations of
compounds that were really toxic to
human beings but that was before any
kind of testing was done and those
particular varieties were pulled off the
market after they were released as I
said plants protect themselves from
insects animals and pathogens by a
variety of strategies some of which
include producing quite toxic chemicals
but the good news is that the ability to
analyze the complete chemical
composition of a crop has gotten
extremely good and be
or a crop plant is introduced the
develop Merce submits information that
compares the chemical composition of the
original variety with that of the
modified variety okay but that only
applies to those varieties that were
modified by molecular techniques curious
next question is this could GM foods
contain new allergens
now most allergies are caused by a
handful of proteins and the amount of
information available about an allergen
is increasing all the time but we don't
understand it completely each protein
for which and genetic instructions are
being introduced must be tested at
pretty high concentrations both for
toxicity and allergenicity and if
there's any slight indication that it
could be an allergen or even if come
even if the gene comes from a plant like
a peanut plant which does produce a
common allergen it must be tested for
allergenicity so what I can tell you is
that GM foods are tested more than any
crop ever produced by conventional
breeding chemical mutagenesis or
radiation mutagenesis was ever tested by
the time has passed through all the
tests at GM food is frankly no more
likely to cause a problem than its
non-gm progenitor another thing worried
people worry about is genes escaping and
causing problems gene transfer from
crops to other plants is now called gene
flow what you need to know and is just
common sense is that plants have to
belong to the same species in order to
trade genes plant genes travel two ways
either in seeds or in pollen which is
carried by wind and my insects cross
pollination which is what it used to be
called is frankly a familiar problem to
farmers and particularly for seed
producers for example if you go
little patch of sweet corn in the middle
of your fodder corn you're not going to
get sweet corn you he'll get starchy
fodder corn sweet corn some mutant for
those of you came last night it's a
recessive that can't convert the sugar
it collects in the kernels to the normal
storage form which is starch pollen made
by the fodder corn will contain the
normal genes that code for the enzymes
the conferred sugar to starch so you
have to keep them quite separate another
example is rapeseed and canola canola
oil is regarded as one of the most
healthful oils today canola is a simple
mutant derivative of rapeseed rapeseed
oil is high in in something called
Aroostook acid which turned out not to
be very good for people canola is simply
rapeseed that has a mutation that
prevents the production of the Aroostook
acid rapeseed and canola are very
closely related plants and farmers
growing both have to be keenly mindful
of keeping them separate so this is not
a new problem for farmers whether genes
can escape into wild plants depends on
the plant whether it matters it depends
on the tree corn for example has wild
relatives in Central and South America
but not in most of North America or most
places that it's grown around the world
so the first requirement is that there
be a local weed species that can cross
hybridize with the plant in question and
the other issue is the trait itself
herbicide resistance for example is a
potential management problem for farmers
but probably not a big concern in the
wild where herbicides are not used so
the answer the first question is it
simply depends there's not a blanket
answer you have to look at the crop the
adjacent what grows in the immediate
vicinity and what the trait is these are
the kinds of issues that the
and the UCA worry about when they
examine new crops for release now will
Jam crops reduce biodiversity the dumped
biodiversity issue has different sides
to it some people mean crop diversity
and other means others mean the
diversity of species other than the crop
plants and both are significant issues
but rather different crop biodiversity
issue was much in the news in recent
years when BT genes which came from
bacterium were introduced to the corn by
molecular techniques by companies like
Monsanto as I described to you earlier
and they were discovered in Mexican land
races these are the beautiful colorful
strains that are a specialty in many
areas of Mexico
but the fact of the matter is that
farmers grow these beautiful strains are
constantly selecting them for how they
look and how they grow if they were able
to derive an insect resistant line it
would actually help them and their
ability to maintain these strains the
biggest problem would be the patents
surrounding the BT gene now another
story that captured media headlines a
few years back was that was that the
larvae of monarch butterfly's died when
fed BT corn pollen in the laboratory
it's not a big surprise since these
butterflies are closely related to
insects that the BT was introduced to
control but butterflies actually don't
eat power they eat milkweed which
generally doesn't quote grow in farmer's
fields nonetheless in response to the
worldwide concern that the story aroused
a very large study was done to assess
the potential impact of BT pollen on
monarch butterfly larvae in the field
the study stretch from Maryland to
Canada and measured everything
imaginable how far the corn pollen goes
from the fields how much milkweed is in
them
where it falls on the milkweed plant so
forth the results were published in five
back-to-back papers in the preceding
Proceedings the National Academy of
Sciences their conclusion what is in the
worst case scenario they could construct
only about one of 2,500 larvae might be
affected that compares with about 90% or
more death rate caused by conventional
pesticides needless to say this did not
make headlines around the world on the
larger issue of biodiversity that is the
biodiversity that's preserved in wild
wild ecosystems of all kinds I like to
quote the words of Peter Raven he's the
director of the Missouri Botanical
Garden and a tireless champion of
biodiversity around the world he says
nothing has driven more species to
extinction or cause more instability in
the world's ecosystems than the
development of an agriculture sufficient
to feed 6.3 billion people it's
important to know the following to get
your around your arms around what this
means for biodiversity first the world's
human population as I said much earlier
is expected to grow somewhere in the
neighborhood - somewhere in the
neighborhood of nine billion people in
the coming decades before it stops
growing second many people know that
fact but second the amount of farm would
be in cultivation hasn't changed in 50
years we are losing good cropland to
desertification salinization and
urbanization as fast as we're adding it
by chopping down species rich tropical
forests in s fault as someone says so
eloquently is the lands last crop the
choice comes down to biodiversity or
food unless unless we can do more with
less
Raven says to assert the GM techniques
are a threat to biodiversity is to state
the exact opposite of the truth the less
focused and productive this agriculture
is the more destructive effects will be
what he's saying is simply that if we
want to preserve biodiversity
we have to get better at growing food on
the land that we already quite already
cultivate and we have to get quite a lot
better at it well okay if all that I've
been saying is true why is there so much
resistance to the new molecular methods
of crop modification here I'm not sure I
have a great answer but what I can do is
show you an example from the past and
it's not a unique example today we
consider the elimination of the scourge
of smallpox through vaccination as a
real achievement of mankind this is a
disease that kills 1/3 of those as
infects and disrupt figures virtually
all the rest but back when governments
began to compel their citizens to be
vaccinated resistance to the procedure
was considerable anti vaccination
societies which by the way persist today
became especially vocal during the late
19th century many anti vaccination
vaccinators believed that vaccination
was as George Bernard Shaw put it a
filthy piece of witchcraft which did
more harm than good
opponents of compulsory vaccination were
varied some saw the issue in terms of
civil liberties arguing that governments
should not for citizens to undergo any
medical treatment against their will
others believed vaccination was
dangerous insisting that thousands are
killed by annually by vaccination and
still others
especially in India from the use of
vaccines derived from cows to being
acceptable the story of how the disease
was finally eradicated through
persuasion and even sometimes by a bit
of force is a fascinating one it has
actually many parallels to the present
controversy about GMO foods here's a
cartoon from the early eighteen hundreds
it shows people turning into cows
because of the vaccinations that's
because of cow pox virus milkmaids who
were exposed to the disease this
particular disease of cows didn't get
smallpox people eventually figured out
that cow pox virus cross protected
people from smallpox fires without
making them sick so they started in
inoculating people with cow pox fighters
hence the cartoon people were worried
that the cow pox virus would turn them
into cows so why does it matter whether
we accept and use these methods why
can't did we just do what we're doing
well let me share the words of the
Kenyan Florence Wambugu with you let me
tell you a little bit about her first
when she was 13 even though the food was
rather scarce her mother sold the family
cow to pay for Florence to go to a
boarding school 10 miles away her mother
needed permission from the village
council to sell the cow and most people
thought she was crazy for educating the
daughter rather than marrying her off
well buco got a PhD in England and plant
pathology and went back to Africa for a
number of years to work on deriving a
virus resistant strain of sweet potato
here's a healthy one there's a sick one
it's a staple part in that part of the
world speak potatoes can be counted on
when much else fails then she went to do
research in the US and was actually
invited to Monsanto at Monsanto she used
the same kinds of methods that I
described to you for papayas to develop
a virus resistant potato variety which
she took back to Africa with Monsanto's
blessing they donated the technology to
Africa today while Booga lives and works
in Nairobi champion the importance of
biotechnology to Africa the virus
resistant sweet
potatoes of being grown on the outskirts
of Nairobi according to New York Times
article last month but haven't been
released yet to farmers
well Booga faces some difficult
obstacles groups from pre peace to the
Union of Concerned Scientists fret that
Africa is being manipulated by
multinational corporations in effect
serving as big and potentially dangerous
genetic experiments some Africans are so
worried about planta technology for
example Zambia's government would rather
have its citizens starve and accept
donated food that includes genetically
modified corn concern with these
misunderstandings about genetic
transgenic plants Ron boo goo created
the harvest by a Tech Foundation
international to serve as a pan-african
voice on the issue while BOGO firmly
believes that the potential good far
outweighs the risk like vaccinations or
penicillin there are few people who are
allergic or have a bad reaction
but both do on balance far more good
than harm
she says you people in the developed
world are free to disc 2 to discuss the
merits of genetically modified foods but
can we eat first
thank you for your time and attention
oh now come the hard I don't think they
turned it on yet yes
okay think right I think we should heat
things up just slightly beautiful talk
and very convincing and a real education
that's but become an academic is so that
you can get paid to argue and so let's
do that is it gone off again
no so the talk could be accused of being
slightly one-sided guilty okay so let's
just introduce so let's you mention the
BT corn so anyone of us here can go to
MEDLINE or Google Scholar and do a
search on recent studies on BT corn
which I did and it's absolutely true
that it's a complete mess half of the
studies claim that there's no
demonstrable deleterious effect another
half say they're very definitely is and
I can quote them but the point here
would be that presumably we all live by
this dictum right that absence of
evidence is not evidence of absence
give me that there is some ambiguity
remaining as to the possible harmful
effects of eating corn is it advisable
to release it into the wild where once
we've released it we have limited
control that actually has a lot of
questions invented them I can't comment
on those studies because there are good
studies and bad studies and
unfortunately a lot of the studies just
as in the drug industry because a lot of
the development happens inside of
companies the studies aren't released so
I think
first of all you have to look at the
quality of the study and second the
other part of your question is released
into the loved crop plants don't live in
corn seeds as I tried to show you
attached so firmly that even if a whole
ear stays in the field the kernels
germinate right there you see for
example when people when farmers rotate
corn and soybeans you'll see an
occasional Portland sticking up through
them those are called volunteers and
their problem but it's not the day of
the Triffids they don't jump the fence
and take over the world
well we can do that jumping the fence in
a second but there is this problem of
you talked a little bit about this issue
because sometimes get that's called
non-target specificity or Target
specificity and in a number of studies
there was the observation that so make
him provide a plant with a toxin that is
intended to target Coleoptera for
example but also would kill Lepidoptera
I gave you that and also
phylogenetically quite distant groups
like new rostrum and so one of the
things I think the neuro
Russ prism does my dear sorry yeah it's
a little bit tricky as you're holding it
I imagine speaking I believe it or not
so notice that these questions are so
comfy yeah they are it's know that there
are more distantly related insect groups
like the lace wings that also were
sensitive to the genetically modified
plants whereas the original intention
was to target exclusively if possible
the collie opera and so I think that's
late 90s the discovery that the
confidence people had in their ability
to target specific insect groups was
probably misplaced um I don't think
entomologists
were particularly unaware of the target
specificity of BT but again I think you
have to put it in context if you spray a
pesticide a chemical pesticide on the
field you kill somewhere between 90 and
95 percent of what lives in that field
if you put the toxin gene in the plant
it's only the insects that munch on the
planet so the death rate is much lower I
think that people are simply unaware of
the use of pesticides anything that will
reduce pesticide use really is
beneficial even though I mean pesticides
are very much less specific
well no but presumably if vgn plum were
to become ubiquitous then the janitor is
effects would also be highly non
localized so even though it's true that
it's only the insects munching on the
plant if those are the only plants we
possess then all of the insects have no
option but to mention I it's not clear
to me how you would accomplish I mean
the problem is that I think what you're
missing is that crop plants are
dependent on people for propagation okay
we have made sure that that's true over
well perhaps if you wait until then I
might ask let me yeah okay so something
wrong with the with the mics we're not
we really are not mumbling it's an
English accent hey let me just wait
before let me just one question because
before we go to the questions
there's jumping the fence so you
mentioned the case of transgenic lee
modified plants being found in oaxaca
now mexico bans transgenic a modified
plants so this is a highly non local or
we call the global propagation of a GM
the other case which is quite well-known
which i is this is the so called
Starling gene and the Starling gene was
created by the company called a ventures
crop sciences
it's a French company and this gene has
infiltrated into aggressed as we call it
into American plants and over five years
of this very deliberative attempt to
remove that gene from American plants
with very little success
now given that avenges owns the patent
there are all sorts of awful thorny
issues related to who owns the plant
that that particular gene has integrates
into so how do we deal with a world
where all of these large companies are
claiming ownership based on the
introgression of genes which local
farmers had no ability to control there
are many issues that you've articulated
there and introgression that's kind of
an interest I can't take them all
because they're all sort of in a big pot
here can I take one piece ok so the
claim in the case of the Mexican
varieties the original publication claim
exactly what you what you said
introgression is when a gene actually
enters and becomes part of the of the
genetic makeup
such that all the other stuff is gone
that takes multiple generations of back
crossing to get rid of all the other
strengths that isn't the way crop plants
work okay for the most part farmers
today buy their seeds not because they
have to they can plant whatever they
want to but because they are guaranteed
disease resistant that are yield more
etc that's particularly important hybrid
corn isn't is it kept because the hybrid
vigor which comes from the whole
breeding process breaks down very
quickly now there's this whole stuff
about introgression but so far that let
me go back to the first thing that you
cited which was the claim that there
were there was there were genes inter
dressed into the local corn
introgression takes many many
generations and that simply people took
that data and reanalyzed it and what
they realized was that what the
scientists had identified as
introgression was just simply erroneous
magnification of genes they simply
analyzed they should have been able to
figure that out the paper was retracted
all kinds of stuff like that nonetheless
it's almost inevitable that that gene
will enter the population that's more of
a problem for Monsanto than anything
else or for the company's right than it
is for the people because if it's a
beneficial gene especially that
beautiful colored corn if you still had
all the traits and you integrate a
disease resistance gene or a dense
secretary
you'd be in a better place if you if you
owned it if you owned it okay and and in
fact and in fact that's a problem for
the company now the companies generally
it's expensive to sue in the cases that
have come up that there's a very famous
morning a canola farmer who actually
propagated I think he was going to go
into the business of doing his name is
Percy Schmeiser and a number of courts
looked at all the evidence and they
decided he was deliberately doing it so
they ruled against him but Monsanto
isn't gonna go after little farmers but
this happens - it's just they aren't
going to get anything out of it it's
that simple
all right well thank you thank you
graciously take your thorny questions I
think this I would I think what you did
wondering would you like to ask you a
question now
but kiss let me may i please say that in
fact it was it went through several
court trials and the seed were test it
turned out that unlock you know that he
didn't know it but he had actually taken
his seed for testing and sometimes the
testing companies keep a little of that
seed and when that was reanalyzed it
turned out that a very large fraction of
it was herbicide resistant in the only
way that you can do that is by spraying
herbicide and picking the seeds that
survived sorry he did it another
question another from another person
well that was a major concern originally
and so anticipating that that might
happen what companies designed was an
agreement between farmers and companies
that they would set aside what are
called refugia areas that are planted in
non BT crops the principle being that if
the insects any insect resistant
survivor from the BT region would have a
higher probability of breeding with it
with an insect from the BT non resistant
population and that would decrease the
rate at which resistance arose now
people worried a lot about this and it
turned out that the compliance without
some farmers didn't even know about it
the complain
it was probably less than anybody
expected certainly in the early years
but a recent study completed within the
last couple of years by entomologist
showed that the BT resistance hadn't
increased and that was a real surprise
in fact the entomologist who was the
principal investigator on that said in a
press conference that you know if he had
said that seven years earlier and nobody
would have believed him so the the
bottom line is that it actually is not
as big a problem as people thought
originally number one number two even
given that it turns out to be not as big
a problem what companies have started to
do which is a smart idea is to double up
on those resistance genes so that insect
would have to have two independent
mutations to become resistant now the
probability of imitation per generation
and so forth is pretty small like one in
a million but if you go one in a million
times one in a million
that's a very very small number so
actually it is not the case that this
will never happen it is the case that
unlike pesticides which of course do the
same thing you get pesticide resistance
people are thinking more about it in
order to make this a longer resist cycle
until you have to reinvent it the
question is is can is there
reproducibility of genetically modified
crops can you grow them actually the
answer to that particularly with corn is
that
it's the early 30s farmers pretty much
gone over to buying hybrid corn no that
is an invention that the science of
which goes back to the turn of the
century when it was discovered that
inbred varieties which made puny little
plants if crust made big healthy plants
in the first generation but that all
falls apart subsequently now
interestingly the history of the
introduction of hybrid varieties has was
resisted by the farmers they said gee we
don't want to be dependent on companies
we don't we just want to keep our seed
and grow it no the head of a retired
gentleman by the name of Don doback who
was the head of the plant breeding
department of pioneer hybrid sent me the
following story by email when I was
writing my book he said you know my dad
like everybody else resisted introducing
hybrid corn but back in 1936 there was a
severe drought and the only thing he
said that was worth bringing in was the
hybrid corn and that converted farmers
to planting hybrid corn and then it took
off another question
no I from another from another person
well is it
that was a major concern originally and
so anticipating that that might happen
what companies designed was an agreement
between farmers and companies that they
would set aside water called refugia
areas that are planted in non-bt crops
the principle being that if the insects
any insect resistant survivor from the
BT region would have a higher
probability of breeding with it with an
insect from the BT non resistant
population and that would decrease the
rate at which resistance arose now
people worried a lot about this and it
turned out that the compliance without
some farmers didn't even know about it
the compliance of it was probably less
than anybody expected certainly in the
early years but a recent study completed
within the last couple of years by
entomologist showed that the BT
resistance hadn't increased and that was
a real surprise in fact the entomologist
who was the principal investigator on
that said in a press conference that you
know if he had said that seven years
earlier and nobody would have believed
him so the the bottom line is that it
actually is not as big a problem as
people thought originally number one
number two even given that it turns out
to be not as big a problem what
companies have started to do which is a
smart idea is to double up on those
resistance gene
so the insect would have to have two
independent mutations to become
resistant now the probability of
imitation for generation and so forth is
pretty small like one in a million
but if you go one in a million times one
in a million
that's a very very small number so
actually it is not the case that this
will never happen it is the case that
unlike pesticides which of course do the
same thing you get pesticide resistance
people are thinking more about it in
order to make this a longer resist cycle
until you have to reinvent it the
question is is can is there
reproducibility of genetically modified
crops can you grow them actually the
answer to that particularly with corn is
that since the early 30s farmers pretty
much have gone over to buying hybrid
corn no that is an invention that the
science of which goes back to the turn
of the century when it was discovered
that inbred varieties which made puny
little plants if crust made big healthy
plants in the first generation but that
all falls apart subsequently now
interestingly the history of the
introduction of hybrid varieties has was
resisted by farmers they said gee we
don't want to be dependent on companies
we don't we just want to keep our seed
and grow it now the head of the retired
gentleman by the name of Don doback who
was the head of the plant breeding
department of Pioneer
hybrid sent me the following story by
email when I was writing my book he said
you know my dad like everybody else
resisted introducing hybrid corn but
back in 1936 there was a severe drought
and the only thing he said that was
worth bringing in was the hybrid corn
and that converted farmers to planting
hybrid corn and then it took off today
almost all of it is - but then he had a
little footnote to that he said you know
the next year my dad kept some of that
corn and he planted it out and he said
my dad said I just wanted to know if the
professors were right he said it wasn't
worth even bringing in so that that
hybrid vigor which people really don't
even understand yet is what is what you
see growing out when you when you travel
across the country and you see these
fantastically productive fields of crime
of course you can plant them you would
not have the yield that you had in the
previous generation that's the point yes
okay can I can i summaries your
statement and go on to other questions
uh-huh I think you know there are people
who have had bad reaction
what would it be okay if I if I took
some questions and I'm not sure I could
I just before I'm sorry I'm interrupting
I forgot to announce the fact that
Garcia Street books and making Nina's
book available at the back and I think
you're gonna after the questions gonna
be signing jokes but forgive me I don't
mean to be rude but but I would like to
answer a few other questions would that
be okay because you didn't really have a
question a statement okay yes
okay the question is are the companies
that are breeding BT corn guarding
against another Texas cytoplasm
catastrophe what he is referring to is
that there was a blight that was that
corn plant so back in the 70s and 60s
corn plants weren't to make the hybrid
corn you have to have one strain of one
genetic Constitution on the other the
male parent and the female parent have
to be separated on an actual corn can't
fear of male and female so you have to
in order for it not to self fertilize
you have to take away the tassel people
identified mutations that made the
plants male sterile so they were still
female infertile but male sterile that
means that they didn't have to go
through and cut off the tassels which is
called detasseling now it turned out
that that particular mutant it's a
mutation in the mitochondria and it was
particularly stood made the plants
particularly susceptible to a rust that
was coming north and that in I think it
was 1972 or so 70 70 80 okay maybe 70 I
didn't get my year right really knocked
down the corn yield what happened after
that is that companies got really this
was this was in the days before Monsanto
you know bought so many companies and
now pioneer is own buddy DuPont but the
companies basically got very
conservative they stopped using those
sterile strains and they went back to
mechanical
um so the question is why didn't I
mention these okay so the question is I
didn't I didn't I didn't mention
modifications such as adding a fish gene
or I'm not familiar with that but the
infant the insects certain kinds of fish
and plants make certain proteins that
change the way ice crystals form they've
come to be called antifreeze proteins
but they really have a very interesting
mechanism because basically what happens
is that they bind to the developing ice
crystal and prevent its growth now they
were originally isolated in fish that
grow in very cold waters like in the
Antarctic the seawater is below the
freezing temperature of the fish the
fish's blood as it were okay
and so it's an extremely important
survival mechanism but it turns out that
these kinds of proteins are not you're
not fishy or what have you they are
proteins that are made in insects
they're made in fish they're made in
plants and you're referring to a project
that never got off the ground because it
didn't work so a company hmm
back in then probably early 80s decided
remember the name of the company I'm not
sure it even exists anyway anyway
they're so they've wanted to add these
genes to tomato plants so that they
would tomato plant so the tomatoes could
be frozen it didn't work so that but
there's there are other modifications
like for example the bacterial genes
that actually nucleates is crystal
formation and the idea there was to
develop to delete that gene and that
kind of fell on the horns of the early
controversies so people stopped
developing them because there were
demonstrators that you know trash the
fields and all kinds of stuff like that
let's take some questions from the back
how about way back there
are there people working on genetically
modifying corn so that it could be used
more efficiently to make ethanol I would
have said yes except they're actually
modifying it to make a more efficient
fuel that ethanol butanol turns out to
be better and yes people are modifying
not the corn plant so much as the
process of converting sugar to a fuel
that has a higher energy value well I
know for one that DuPont is doing that
yes
the question is with the genetic
modification of soybeans does that raise
a concern about monoculture monoculture
and a particular genetic modification or
two separate issues monoculture is
monoculture and yes it does indeed bear
with it the kind of susceptibility that
surfaced with that particular rust right
that is the conceit is a constant
concern because organisms mutate the
rusts are particularly good at it
monoculture is efficient but it is
vulnerable the genetic modifications
don't make it better or worse herbicide
tolerance is a problem much of it is
quite labile and it can in some cases
the spontaneous so you can you can get
herbicide resistance
what herbicides do is they affect
pathways that plants have that people
don't have which is why they're not
toxic to people but the plant can fight
back it can mutate to be herbicide
resistant so that's a constant
management problem and again as with the
insect resistance the best management
tools are multiple crop rotation and
different multiple different herbicides
at the moment there are a number of
different ones and how fast herbicide
resistance emerges is the only question
that's it that's an ongoing there's a
long-standing question there yes but
also we should take why don't - because
you need to have time just to make some
signings so if that's
earlier speech analogy
vaccination of animals and humans to
animals vaccination by death
okay we're talking about taking the
genes from you know fish hands
tomatoes okay because I think we need to
deal with the pollution problem you
don't want to give any more of them okay
why do you get one more question the
mission we should wrap up here's
somebody that's really eager back
zero-zero never got a dime Philip sorry
you